أعربت كل من الولايات المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية عن
قلقهما من أن الحرب بين
إسرائيل وحماس يمكن أن تتسع إلى
حرب إقليمية. الفرق بين
الولايات المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية هو أن المملكة
كانت تدعو منذ بداية
هذا الأمر تقريبًا إلى وقف فوري لإطلاق النار
انضم إلي الآن  روبرت جوردان سفير الولايات المتحدة السابق
لدى المملكة العربية السعودية، ولنكن
واضحين تمامًا، لقد
أدانت المملكة بأشد العبارات
العملية البرية الإسرائيلية في غزة، فهي
تضرب مخيم جباليا وأنت تعلم
أنها أوضحت موقفها تمامًا
عندما يتعلق الأمر بوقف إطلاق النار  أو
أنك تعرف في اللغة المخففة ربما من
الناحية الدبلوماسية توقفًا إنسانيًا
على الأقل هل
فوجئت بأي شكل من الأشكال بمدى ارتفاع صوت
هؤلاء السعوديين،
لا، إنها ليست مفاجأة على الإطلاق
لأن السلطات تعتبر نفسها
بالطبع أوصياء على الاثنين
أقدس الأماكن في الإسلام السني
أه عليهم
مسؤولية أوسع بسبب ذلك
وأعتقد أنهم سيجدون أنه من
غير المقبول تقريبًا أه الهراء والتشجيع على
توغل إسرائيلي واسع النطاق في غزة في ظل
هذه الظروف سأخبرك على
انفراد أعتقد أنهم غاز في  ما
فعلته حماس هم ليسوا أصدقاء
لحماس وأعتقد إذا نظرتم إليه
حماس فعلا أه قامت بمحاولة أه
لتقويض عدد من الأنظمة العربية الخليجية
أه بما فعلوه لذلك أه
أعتقد سرا سنرى  السعوديون
أكثر تعاوناً لكن
تصريحاتهم العلنية هي شيء
آخر، المملكة بالتأكيد تشاركنا
المخاوف حول هذه المنطقة من
خطر التصعيد الذي نسمعه يتردد
في جميع أنحاء هذه المنطقة هنا في الخليج
وفي جميع أنحاء المنطقة من خلال
عدسة الرياض بالطبع تورط السعودية.  إن إعلان
الحوثيين المدعومين من إيران في اليمن
مسؤوليتهم عن محاولات شن
هجمات على الحدود الجنوبية لإسرائيل يجب أن
يكون مصدر قلق حقيقي، لذا ما الذي تعتقد
أن السعوديين يبحثون عنه في
واشنطن اليوم؟ ما الذي
تبحث عنه واشنطن من السعوديين وأين
تعتقد أن هؤلاء؟
يمكن للمحادثات أن تجتمع معًا، حيث يمكن
صياغة الاتفاقات في هذه المرحلة نظرًا
لأنها كما تعلمون تجلس على
طرفين مختلفين تمامًا عما يجب أن يحدث
بعد ذلك هنا، أعني كما قلت أن المملكة
تدعو بوضوح إلى وقف إطلاق النار في
هذه
المرحلة وأنا  أعتقد أنه علينا أن نكون أه
واضحين بشأن الشروط أه عندما يدعون إلى وقف
إطلاق النار هم في الأساس أه
يقترحون أن حماس يجب أن تنتصر وعلى
الإسرائيليين أن يتنحوا بالكامل
ولكن عندما يطالبون
بممر إنساني أو وقف مؤقت
الأغراض الإنسانية أه هذا
نوع مختلف من الأجهزة التي قد تكون
قابلة للاستخدام هنا أه للسماح بمرور آمن لعدد
من المدنيين لمغادرة
شمال غزة على الأقل لذلك أعتقد أننا نريد
أن نكون حذرين للغاية بشأن ما
نفهم أنهم يقولونه  أه
ثانيًا أعتقد أنهم على الأرجح
سيواصلون مع الولايات المتحدة بهدوء
طلب بعض من نفس الأشياء التي
كانوا يطلبونها بموجب
خطة التطبيع السعودية الإسرائيلية أه التي كانت الوصول إلى
المعدات العسكرية الأمريكية أه
التكنولوجيا النووية أه يقولون شيئًا
للفلسطينيين وأعتقد  هذا
شيء يجب
مناقشته